another deadly mass shooting in this
country it's a 146 mass shooting so far
this year and we're only 101 days into
the new year think about that for just a
second there are only so many ways to
say the same thing over and over and
over again this time we're talking about
the people in Kentucky they are grieving
after man killed five people and wounded
eight others inside the Old National
Bank in downtown Louisville now police
say the shooter was live streaming the
attack before officers shot him to death
the five people who were murdered all
worked for the bank they are 57 year old
Deanna Eckert 40-year-old Joshua Barrick
63 year old Thomas Elliott 45 year old
Juliana farmer and 64 year old James
Tutt